EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S EVENT --
TODAY'S HEARING.
IT IS GOING TO BE AN EVENT. TWO
THEY WERE COVERING A VARIETY OF
SUBJECTS ACROSS DEPARTMENTS
MOSTLY IN RESPONSE TO REQUESTS
MADE IN APRIL BY THE GOVERNOR.
WE'RE EXPECTING TO RECEIVE THE
MAY REVISION TOMORROW I WILL
HEAR THE HEAR THE THOSE NEW
REVISIONS TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IN HEARINGS ON MONDAY
AND TUESDAY.
MAY THIRTEENTH AND FOURTEENTH.
WITH THE EXPECTATION OF TAKING
ACTIONS EARLY THE FOLLOWING WEEK.
I DO ASK THAT YOU PLEASE CONSULT
THE DAILY FILE FOR MORE DETAILS.
WE WILL START WITH ISSUE -- ONE
BUT UNTIL WE GET A QUORUM WE ARE
GOING -- TO TAKE ONE ITEM OUT OF
ORDER.
IT'S ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVEN ADVOCACY PROPOSAL FOR IN
THE CONGREGATIONS UNITED FOR
CHANGE.
I WILL ASK DOCTOR WOULD TO
PLEASE [inaudible]
TAKE THIS [inaudible]
SELECT
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IT'S SUCH A PLEASURE FOR ME --
TO TO INTRODUCE -- AN
ORGANIZATION FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS WORKED
TIRELESSLY ON AND THE ISSUE OF
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
WE DO RECOGNIZE HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMUNITY IS AWARE.
OF THEIR POWER THERE THE THE THE
THE NECESSITY TO BE ABLE TO
REACH AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE.
AND IF THEY ARE NOT ENGAGE THE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IS
AVAILABLE IN THE COMMUNITY.
THE THE ORGANIZATION FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT HAS
WORKED WITH TENS OF THOUSANDS.
IN OUR COMMUNITY TO TRAIN THEM
AND THEN FROM THERE TO TRAIN THE
TRAINERS ESSENCE -- IS
PRESENTING A PROPOSAL AND I'D
LIKE TO ASK THAT THE PRESENT
THAT AT THIS TIME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
HI MY NAME IS TOM DOLAN OF THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF INLAND
CONGREGATIONS UNITED FOR CHANGE
I SEE YOU SEE.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR I SEE
YOU SEE.
I SEE YOU SEE IS A COLLABORATION
OF SIXTY TWO DIVERSE
CONGREGATIONS AROUND THE INLAND
REGION SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
AND OUR WORK IS MULTI
GENERATIONAL SO WE DO A LOT OF
WORK WITH YOUNG PEOPLE.
WITH AN WITH ADULTS AND WE
COMBINE THAT WORK BETWEEN YOUNG
PEOPLE AND ADULTS IT'S
MULTICULTURAL.
WE WORK WITH UP FOR A PAYCHECK
COMMUNITY INDIGENOUS COMMUNITY
AND THE EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY
WE WORK WITH LATINO AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES ALL AROUND
THE REGION AND WERE MULTI RACIAL.
OUR WORK IS OUR WORK TO IMPROVE
COMMUNITIES -- WHAT WE DO IS WE
TRAIN GRASSROOTS -- MOMS KIDS
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS -- TO BE
ENGAGED IN THEIR CIVIC LIFE --
ACROSS THE REGION EVERY DAY.
HUNDREDS OF OUR FOLKS ARE
MEETING WITH THEIR CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS.
OUR SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS CITY
COMMISSIONS.
WHEREVER WERE WORKING TO BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS WE BELIEVE THAT
POWER IN A COMMUNITY IS
EXERCISED THROUGH RELATIONSHIPS.
AND THOSE RELATIONSHIPS LEVERAGE
THE LEADERSHIP THAT IS EMBEDDED
IN OUR COMMUNITY REGULAR PEOPLE
WORKING PEOPLE HAVE A LOT OF
LEADERSHIP ABILITY -- WHAT THEY
DO THAT AND -- IS -- WE LEVERAGE
THEIR LEADERSHIP THEIR KNOWLEDGE
AND THEIR CAPACITY A BOTH YOUTH
AND ADULTS TO ADDRESS SOCIAL
ISSUES.
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND OUR
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE REGION.
EVERY YEAR -- I SEE YOU SEE
WHAT'S UP WE TRAIN AN AVERAGE OF
FOUR TO FIVE THOUSAND GRASSROOTS
COMMUNITY LEADERS.
AND WE TRAIN THEM TO TRAIN THEIR
PEERS.
SAUL OUR CONGREGATIONS REPRESENT
MORE THAN SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
FAMILIES IN THE REGION.
AND THE PEOPLE WE TRAIN OUR
GOING INTO THEIR COMMUNITY AND
TRAINING OTHER PEOPLE FROM THE
COMMUNITY -- OVER THE PAST
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS CENTS ARE
FOUND WE WERE FOUNDED.
THESE LEADERS HAVE TRAIN.
AND HELP CREATE AN IN SCHOOLS
AND HELP CREATE -- AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS.
MOVE OUR SCHOOLS ENGAGE
NEIGHBORS.
IN JOB TRAINING AND JOB
DEVELOPMENT.
HELP BRING HEALTHCARE
OPPORTUNITIES. TOO LOW COM
INCOME RESIDENTS ACROSS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA -- ANGELA AND HER
FAMILY AND FRIENDS THAT'S HAMMER
A HIGH SCHOOL ARE ONE EXAMPLE OF
THE IMPACT.
THAT AN INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY
LEADERSHIP.
HOUSE ON THE SOCIAL FABRIC OF
OUR REGION.
JUST OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
ANGELA.
AND A GROUP OF OF MAYBE A
HUNDRED HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
THE AIR IN SAN BERNADINE ALL IN
THIS CASE -- LEVERAGE THEIR
LEADERSHIP TO BRING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO STUDENTS
ACROSS THE CITY.
THEIR WORK HELPED DEVELOP A
PARTNERSHIP OF HEALTH CARE.
PROVIDERS.
UNIVERSITIES AND OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT WITH FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS TO ADDRESS THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
THAT SPELLED OUT IN NOW WE HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THROUGH
THEIR WORK AND THROUGH THEIR
IDEAS.
THAT THAT THOSE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ARE NEEDED ON CAMPUSES
WE STARTED TWO YEARS AGO THE
FIRST YEAR WE HAD IT AT EIGHT
HIGH SCHOOL AT EIGHT SCHOOL
CAMPUSES -- THROUGHOUT THE K..
TWELVE BOB NOW IT'S AT SIXTEEN
CAMPUSES.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
DEDICATED.
A SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
OF THEIR FUNDING. TO PUT TRAINED.
ELEMENT OF MEDIC MEDIC -- HEALTH
CARE WORKERS WITH CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE THAT EVERYONE OF
THOSE CAMPUSES TO ATTEND THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THEY'VE ALSO MADE A COMMITMENT
BECAUSE OF THE WORK OF ANGELA
AND OUR YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES.
TO EXPAND THIS OVERTIME TO
EVERYONE OF THE SCHOOLS NINETY
THREE PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN OUR CITY.
THEY'VE ALSO CREATED
PARTNERSHIPS SO IT'S NOT ALL
PUBLIC FUNDING.
WE HAVE PARTNERSHIPS WITH KAISER
HEALTH.
PARTNERSHIPS WITH SENT US SAME
SAME BURDENS MEDICAL CENTER AND
WITH LOMA LINDA UNIVERSITY SO
THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING FREE
SERVICES AND AND ADDING TO THAT
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT THE DISTRICT IS PROVIDING.
WITH MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WORTH
OF SERVICES FOR OUR FAMILIES
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT.
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT DOES IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHEN WE TRAIN PEOPLE
AND BRING THEIR LEADERSHIP.
OUR MANY SUCCESSES DEMONSTRATE
THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE THE
MOST VALUABLE ASSET IN EVERY
COMMUNITY AND THAT WE ARE ALL
BETTER WHEN WE WORK TOGETHER.
ACROSS DIFFERENCES AND THAT THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF OUR
FAMILY.
IS MOST ACT IMPACTED WHEN WE
LEVERAGE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENTS.
WITH BROAD CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
I'M REPRESENTING WORKING AND
POOR FAMILIES FROM THE INLAND
REGION WHEN I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. TO INCREASE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT IN OUR AREA AND IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND TO ENGAGE THE TREMENDOUS
RICHES.
OF CULTURAL UP PARTICIPATION
GRASSROOTS ACTIVITY AND
LEADERSHIP IN RECOGNIZING AND
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
YOUR SUPPORT FOR OUR PROPOSAL
WILL DEEPEN PARTICIPATION OUR
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
IN OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS AND
WILL BRING THE VOICES AND
RESOURCE OF YOUTH.
PARENTS AND FAMILIES INTO
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE MANY
URGENT NEEDS AND OUR REGION.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US TIME TO
SPEAK AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
DID YOU DID YOU WANT TO HAVE.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY AS WELL OKAY IT
WOULD WEEK OF ALL OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ANGELA GOVERNMENTS
AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
ENDING CONDITION AND FOR CHANGE
I AM CURRENTLY A SENIOR AT
SAMBAR YOU KNOW HIGH SCHOOL.
AND THE CITY OF SAN BRUNO
CALIFORNIA AND I'M ALSO STUDENT
ORGANIZER WITH A C. UC.
I SEE YOU SEE THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT HELPS.
WELL IN DIFFERENT COMMITTEES
UNDERSTAND THE DECISIONS THAT
AFFECT THEM HOW THESE DECISIONS
ARE MADE AND HOW THE COMMUNITY
CAN BE PART OF SUCH PROCESS
SIMPLY BY GETTING INVOLVED WE
LISTEN AND LEARN THE CONCERNS IN
A COMMUNITIES.
WITHIN RESEARCH.
DISCUSS AND PLAN HOW THESE
ISSUES CAN BE RESOLVED.
WELL I SEE YOU SEE WE HAVE ALSO
WORKED ON A NUMBER OF
NONPARTISAN VOTER ENGAGEMENT
CAMPAIGN CAMPAIGNS WHERE WE HAVE
TALKED TO THOUSANDS OF MOURNERS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. TO ENSURE
THEY GO OUT AND BOTH TO ENSURE
THEY HAVE A VOICE.
THE WORK I SEE YOU SEE DOES HAVE
IMPACT ASSEMBLY NO AREA BECAUSE
IT HAS HELPED.
CREATE A CULTURE WHERE YOUNG
PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF AND ACTUALLY
SO DIFFICULT PHYSICALLY ENGAGE.
THROUGHOUT THESE YEARS THERE
HAVE BEEN MANY YOU'LL TO HAVE
LEARNED THE IMPORTANCE OF
GETTING INVOLVED IN ENGAGE IN
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
I SEE YOU SEE WORKS MULTI
GENERATIONAL WORK YES YOU HAVE
NOT ONLY LEARNED THE IMPORTANCE
OF VOTING AND PARTICIPATING.
IN LOCAL AND STATE ELECTIONS BUT
THEY INFORMED THEIR FAMILIES AND
NEIGHBORS MANY WHO HAVE NEVER
BEEN ACTIVE IN THE COMMUNITY.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT YOU
SHOULD BE INVOLVED BECAUSE YOUR
VOICE IS IMPORTANT BEFORE I
STARTED GETTING INVOLVED WITH
ICY USE HE I DIDN'T KNOW I HAD A
VOICE ALWAYS THOUGHT THE ADULTS
AT THE BIGGER VOICE AND OTHER
ALWAYS HAVE TO DO.
WE ALWAYS HAVE TO DO WHAT THEY
SAY AND OUR OPINIONS DIDN'T
MATTER.
ALSO AS YOU CAN SEE THE TRAIN I
HAVE RECEIVED HAS DEFINITELY
CHANGED ME.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
ALSO POSSIBLE FOR ALL THE YOUTH
IN MY COMMUNITY.
AN EXAMPLE OF HOW YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS ASKING HELP US IMPROVE
COMMITTEE IS THE OF WORK I HAVE
DONE I HAVE COLLABORATED WITH
STUDENTS PARENTS TEACHERS AND TO
FIND RESOURCES. FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN OUR SCHOOLS.
WE KNOW THEM TAMBIéN OUR FAMILY
SUFFER FROM MEANT MANY MENTAL
BY TRAUMA EXPERIENCE.
IN OUR OWN COMMUNITY.
THROUGH ART TIRELESS INTERNET
ORGANIZING WE HAVE GOT IN OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO PARTNER WITH
LOCAL UNIVERSITIES HEALTH
PROVIDERS TO BEGIN PROVIDING
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES OUR
SCHOOLS.
ARE ORGANIZING WORK IS BRINGING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
OF SERVICES TO FAMILIES WHO NEED
IN OUR CITY.
AFTER YOU INVEST IN ME AND MANY
YOUTH AND FAMILIES FOR READY TO
CONTINUE THIS GREAT WORK.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
QUESTIONS.
JUST A QUESTION YOU'VE MENTIONED --
BUT TO BOTH OF YOU PENSION --
MENTAL HEALTH MULTIPLE TIMES
HERE IS THAT ONE OF THE PRIMARY
FOCUSES OF THE OF OF THE PROGRAM
OR IS AT BECAUSE OF THE GREAT
NEED IN THE COMMUNITY RIGHT NOW
SOMETHING YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
WORKING ON NOW YES WELL WE
WORKED ON A WIDE VARIETY AND AND
DO WORK ON A WIDE.
VARIETY OF CONCERNS FOR THE
YOUTH THAT THAT'S ABERDEEN HIGH
SCHOOL AND IN THE ANGELES SCHOOL.
FOR A COUPLE YEARS NOW THAT
MEANT FOCUSING ON GAINING ACCESS
TO MENTAL HEALTH HEALTH SERVICES
AND AM GENERAL HEALTH SERVICES
AT SCHOOLS IN THE DISTRICT.
BUT THE STUDENTS AND WE HAVE
STUDENTS IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY
THAT ARE WORKING ON ISSUES THAT
IMPACT FAMILIES IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY WE HAVE ADULTS.
WORKING ON A PLETHORA OF ISSUES
THE THE WAY THE THE ISSUES GET
DECIDED IS PEOPLE COME TOGETHER
EITHER AND ONE OTHER
CONGREGATIONS ARE AT A SCHOOL.
AND AND WE HAVE TRAINERS WHO
HELP THEM GO THROUGH A PROCESS
OF DISCERNMENT EVERYBODY GETS TO
SAY WE SHOULD WORK ON THIS.
BUT THEN THERE'S A PROCESS WHERE
WE DECIDE WELL WHAT IT IMPACTS
MOST PEOPLE WHAT THE PEOPLE FEEL
THE MOST ABOUT ALSO THE WORK
REAL HARD TO TO BUT THERE'S
REALLY -- HUNDREDS OF ISSUES
THAT WE'VE WORKED ON OVER THE
PAST COUPLE OF DECADES.
AND IT'S IN BOTH -- RIVERSIDE
AND PERCENT ALTERS RIGHT NOW YOU
HAVE NEVER SEPARATING COUNTY AND
AND WE HAVE PARTNERS.
THROUGH OUR FAITH THE NETWORKS
ACROSS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SEWER.
YEAH I SPENT A COUPLE DAYS LAST
WEEK IN LOS ANGELES WORKING WITH
OUR ORGANIZATIONS THERE.
OKAY PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES WHICH WOULD
BE LIKE TO TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS
OR ANYONE IN THE PUBLIC LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THIS TODAY.
CINEMA THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
WE HAVE TO LEAVE THIS ITEM OPEN
AT THIS POINT BUT THE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANKS FOR MAKING
THE TRIP HERE.
THANK YOU.
CHOICE LIKE SOME PEOPLE FROM HER
DISTRICT
[inaudible]
OF COURSE [inaudible]
THE SERVICE.
ALRIGHT LET'S GO BACK.
LET'S GO BACK TO ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE UNTIL WE REACH A QUORUM AND
THEN WE PLAN TO TAKE A PAUSE SO
THAT WE CAN VOTE ON IT.
ON THE ITEMS.
WE CAN DISCUSS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MARK BECKLEY ON THE ACTING
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING --
WITH ME TODAY IS OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR ADMINISTRATION
THOMAS CAMERON.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OUR
SPRING FINANCE LETTERS TODAY --
THE SPRING FINANCE LETTERS --
BEFORE YOU WOULD DO THE
FOLLOWING.
FIRST ENABLE DEPARTMENTS TO
BRING IN AN ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR TITLE THREE PROGRAMS.
IN THE NINETEEN TWENTY FISCAL
YEAR AND ALL OUR AGENTS ARE AREA
AGENCY.
ON AGING PARTNERS TO EXPAND THE
SERVICES THAT THEY DELIVER TO
OUR SENIOR POPULATION -- WE ALSO
HAVE A PROPOSAL THAT WOULD --
ALLOW OUR TRIPLE A.'S TO PROVIDE
OUR REGION APPLICATION SERVICES
TO NEWLY ELIGIBLE -- CAL FRESH
RECIPIENTS.
AND THEN FINALLY WE HAVE A
TECHNICAL PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
ENABLE THE DEPARTMENT TO BRING --
WHAT WE CALL OUR MET BUT WE'RE
MEDICARE IMPROVEMENTS FOR
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS ACT GRANT
FUNDS IN YOUR BUDGET FASTER AND
ENABLE US TO DISTRIBUTE THOSE
FUNDS YOU ARE?
TRIPLE A PARTNERS AT A FASTER
RATE.
I'D LIKE TO NOW TURN OVER -- THE
PRESENTATION TO MR CAMERON -- TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION ON OUR
PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO BE HERE TODAY
AND RIGHT PROVIDE YOU WITH AN
OVERVIEW OF OUR SPRING FINANCE
LETTERS -- THE FIRST ONE IS OUR
FEDERAL TITLE THREE FUNDING
ARGUMENTATION.
THE DEPARTMENT REQUEST AN
INCREASE IN ITS FEDERAL TITLE
THREE FUNDED FORTY HAVE
SEVENTEEN POINT FOUR EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS.
OF THIS AMOUNT SIXTEEN MILLION
FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND IS FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE
AND EIGHT HUNDRED AND NINETY
SEVEN THOUSAND IS FOR STATE
OPERATIONS.
THIS FUNDING REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA'S PORTION OF
ADDITIONAL TITLE THREE GRANT
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FEDERAL BUDGET ACT.
AND WILL BE DISTRIBUTED TO THE
LOCAL AREA AGENCIES ON AGING AND
LOCAL OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS TO
AUGMENT THEIR CAR GET NUTRITION
HOME DELIVERED MEALS.
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES HEALTH
PROMOTION CARE GIVER SUPPORT.
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN FAMILY
CARE GIVER AND DISEASE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
OF THE SIXTEEN POINT SIX MILLION.
THAT IS DISTRIBUTED OF THE TITLE
THREE FUNDING FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE IT WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED VIA THE FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR THE CALL THE
INTERSTATE FUNDING FORMULA.
AND IT'LL BE ALLOCATED TO EACH
PROGRAM AREA IN THE FOLLOWING
MANNER. NINE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS WILL GO TO NUTRITION
PROGRAMS FOR BOTH CONGREGATE AND
HOME DELIVERED MEALS. FOUR POINT
SIX MILLION WILL GO TO
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROGRAMS.
THREE POINT ONE MILLION WILL GO
TO FAMILY CAREGIVER SUPPORT
PROGRAMS. FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND WILL GO TO
DISEASE PREVENTION AND A HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN THOUSAND WILL GO TO
ON BUTTON PROGRAMS.
THE STATE OPERATIONS PORTION OF
THIS REQUEST IS DEFINED SEVEN
POSITIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL OVERSIGHT AND
ADDITIONAL STATE SUPPORT TO THE
TITLE THREE GRANT PROGRAM.
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE TITLE THREE
REQUEST.
IT HOLD THE QUESTIONS TILL THE
END OF THE PRESENTATION -- THE
NEXT REQUEST WE HAVE IS FOR THE
MEDICARE IMPROVEMENTS FOR
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS ACT OR
MITHA EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE.
THE DEPARTMENT REQUEST A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT TO AMEND
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT UPON APPROVAL
FROM THE PARTNER FINANCE. TO
INCREASE ITS FEDERAL FUNDED
FORTY WHEN ADDITIONAL MID BUT
GRANT FUNDS ARE AWARDED TO THE
STATE.
THIS PROCESS WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO BRING THESE FUNDS
INTO ITS BUDGET MORE QUICKLY AND
DISTRIBUTE THE GRANT FUNDING TO
ITS AREA AGENCY ON AGING
PARTNERS IN A MORE TIMELY MANNER.
THE MIDDLE GRANT IS USED TO
PROVIDE OUR REACH AN APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE VIA LOCAL TRIPOLI'S
TO SENIORS WHO MAY BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE LOW INCOME SUBSIDY AND
THE MEDICARE SAVINGS PROGRAM.
OUR NEXT PROPOSAL IS THE
SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY INCOME
CASH OUT REVERSAL IMPLEMENTATION
VI<c.cyan> AREA AGENCIES ON AGING.</c>
IN THIS PROPOSAL THE DEPARTMENT
REQUEST AN ADJUSTMENT TO
INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY
BY ONE POINT SEVEN ONE EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. TO PROVIDE OUR
REGION APPLICATION ASSISTANCE
VIA LOCAL TRIPOLI'S TO SENIORS
RECEIVING SSI BENEFITS.
WHO MAY BE NEWLY ELIGIBLE FOR
CALIFORNIA?
THESE FUNDS ARE CURRENTLY
BUDGETED WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES AND WILL BE
PASSED THROUGH TO THE DEPARTMENT
AGING VIA AN INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENT.
THE STATE NETWORK OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING WILL PROVIDE
OUR REGION APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE FOR THE POPULATION OF
OLDER ADULT AT THE SITE AT THE
TH P. RECIPIENTS THAT ARE NEWLY
ELIGIBLE FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS WERE
COLLABORATIVE THE WITH THE
TRIPLE A IS TO DEVELOP A
METHODOLOGY TO ALLOCATE THESE
FUNDS TO EACH AGENCY.
THE TRIPLE A.'S WILL BEGIN THESE
OUR REGION ASSISTANCE ACTIVITIES
BEGINNING JULY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS I
WHISPERED WROTE APARTMENT
FINANCE NOTHING HAD HAPPENED A
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD.
NOT ALSO LIKE TO ADD ANOTHER THE
COMMITTEE HAD TWO QUESTIONS AND
ITS AGENDA I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND
TO THOSE QUESTIONS -- WE DID
PROVIDE A HANDOUT PROVIDED BY
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THAT PROVIDED RESPONSES -- BUT
I'M I'M HAPPY -- TO TO TALK
ABOUT THOSE RESPONSES.
ACTUALLY THAT I THINK THAT WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU.
SO THE FIRST QUESTION IS HOW
WILL CDA DO ARE IN OTHER
AFFECTED AGENCIES TRANSMIT
INFORMATION OBSERVATIONS.
AND SUGGESTIONS FOR PROBLEM
SOLVING BACK TO THE SS WHAT
PROTOCOLS ARE IN PLACE.
OR WILL BE TO ENSURE CROSS
DEPARTMENTAL COMMUNICATION
TOWARDS THE STRONGEST
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
INITIATIVE.
SAID RESPOND FOR CROSS
DEPARTMENT COMMUNICATION -- THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES CAL FRESH OUT RICH TEAM
CAN BE AND ALL DEPARTMENTS
RECEIVING OUR REGION APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE FUNDING.
INCLUDING SET WHICH INCLUDES CA
DSS AND DO ARE AS WELL AS OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS FOR PROGRAM KICK
OFF AN ONBOARDING EVENT ON APRIL
TWENTY FIFTH.
THE CONFERENCE TEAM IS ALSO
CONVENING A SERIES OF MONTHLY
MEETINGS WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
CALL CALIBRATION ACTS.
THIS SERIES THAT STARTS THIS
MONTH.
SOCIAL SERVICES IS ALSO
ESTABLISH LOCAL POINTS OF
CONTACT BETWEEN COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICE DEPARTMENTS.
LOCAL AREA AGENCIES ON AGING AN
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS AND
REGIONAL CENTERS TO FACILITATE
THE ON THE GROUND COLLABORATION
AND PROBLEM SOLVING.
ISSUES THAT MIGHT ARISE DURING
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PROGRAM.
INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENT TRAININGS
AND CONFERENCE OUTRAGE WILL ALSO
BE PROVIDED A CDA DSS.
AND YOUR NETWORKS THIS SUMMER.
IDEAS SEAT BY DSS IS LARGEST
PRIME CONTRACTOR -- CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS.
THESE AND PERSON TRAININGS
FOLLOW THE WEAPON ARE TRAINING
SERIES.
THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED ON
CONFERENCE POLICY AN OUTRAGE.
BY DSS -- CDA HIS APPRECIATE ALL
THE SUPPORT AND COOPERATION THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH CAL FRESH TEAM ON
THIS PROJECT.
WE FOUND THAT THE CALIPHATE
STAFF OF BEEN VERY RESPONSIVE TO
OUR NEEDS AND QUESTIONS AND
THOSE ARE TRIPLE A PARTNERS.
AND WE EXPECT THIS HIGH LEVEL OF
COOPERATION SUPPORT CONTINUE
THROUGHOUT THE DURATION OF THE
PROJECT. FOR THE SECOND QUESTION --
IT IT WAS REQUESTED TO PROVIDE A
BREAK OUT OF THE FUNDING -- FOR
THE PROGRAM AND THAT AS BEEN
PROVIDED BY DSS CD THAT HAVE
THAT HANDOUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BEFORE WE TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT I
WOULD LIKE TO ESTABLISH QUORUM.
REYES A HEARING REYES.
FOR FRAZIER.
MATHIS PATTERSON RAMOS RUBIO
DOCTOR WOULD HEAR QUORUM.
THANK YOU WE WILL BE TAKING THE
VOTE TO SINNERS -- MISTER ROEMER
RIDES -- WHICH DENTAL BE TEN
MINUTES.
VERY GOOD NOW LET'S OPEN IT UP
TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE MADAM CHAIR MY CAROL FOR
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY THIS IS ONLY ON OF ITEM
SEE OF THE OF ITEM.
ONE WE ARE FULLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AND IT SOUNDS COMPLETELY
CONSISTENT WITH THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE THE DEPARTMENT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS YES MS RUBIO.
THANK YOU -- I KNOW THIS IS A
COMPLICATED ISSUE AND WE'RE
DOING WERE ATTEMPTING TO DO A
LOT ON MY CONCERN HAS ALWAYS
BEEN AND I KNOW THE BUDGET --
COMMITTEE ALL SOULS OUR CONCERN
IS THAT -- WHEN WE'RE DOING ALL
OF THESE THINGS THAT?
HOW ARE WEGOING TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ALL
OF THESE THEY THESE THINGS
HAPPENING AND WHAT I'VE HEARD
BEFORE WHEN WE?
TRY TO DO TOO MUCH IS LIKE WHY
THOUGHT.
THIS DEPARTMENT S GOING TO DO
IT I THOUGHT THAT I WAS GOING TO
DO IT HOW WE'RE GOING GOING TO
ENSURE.
THAT SOMEBODY IS KIND OF
OVERSEEING EVERYTHING AND WHAT
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURE MEASURES
ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE I
APPRECIATE THE TRAINING AND ALL
THAT BUT HOWEVER WORK WEEK GOING
TO ENSURE THAT THIS IS ALL
HAPPENING INSTEAD OF SAYING WELL.
COMING NEXT YEAR AND SAY WELL WE
THOUGHT THAT SUNSET WAS GOING TO
DO IT SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE AND WHO'S
GOING TO BE.
OVERSEEING THAT THIS IS
IMPLEMENTED CORRECTLY.
RIGHT AND I CAN SPEAK TO
ACCOUNTABILITY FROM -- THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGENTS PERSPECTIVE --
AND I BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM DSS OR WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THE LARGER
QUESTION ACCOUNTABILITY -- I
KNOW THAT WE'VE WORKED REALLY
CLOSELY WITH CALIFORNIA'S.
TO WORK OUT SYSTEMS AND
PROCESSES TO TRACK APPLICATIONS --
THERE'S GOING TO BE -- AN
APPLICATION -- SYSTEM THAT'S
DEVELOPED WHERE WE YOU KNOW KIND
OF PROVIDE APPLICATIONS HOW MANY
HAS BEEN REPORTED.
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING THAT ON A
MONTHLY.
BASIS AS WELL AS A QUARTERLY
BASIS BOTH ONLINE AND IN PAPER --
SO WE WILL HAVE GOOD DATA AND
COMMUNICATION EXCHANGE BETWEEN
CDA AND WITH -- DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES I'M MORE CLEARLY
COMMITTED LIKE I SAY I THINK
THAT SOCIAL SERVICES HAS BEEN
VERY.
RESPONSIVE TO OUR NEEDS THEY
HAVE BEEN -- VERY INTENT TO SET
UP ACCOUNTABILITY STRUCTURES BUT
AGAIN I CAN HAVE YES I SPEAK TO
THAT MORE [inaudible]
YOUR AVAILABLE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PICTURE OF A
CATCH OF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
SOCIAL SERVICES.
HI THIS IS AMONG THE TOP
PRIORITIES THE DEPARTMENT HAS
FOR IMPLEMENTATION WE HAVE A
MASSIVE ORGANIZING TEAM IS
TRACKING THIS -- EVERY TIME I
OPEN THE SPREADSHEET AND SEE THE
NUMBER OF TABS ON THE NUMBER OF
TASKS THAT PEOPLE ARE TRACKING
THAT NEED TO GET DONE.
THEY ALWAYS HAVE DATES
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM THEY ALWAYS
HAVE THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY NAMED
ON IT -- IN THAT WRITTEN HAND
OUT AND AND PURSUANT TO MISTER
BACCHUS PRESENTATION TO YOU --
IT'S CLEAR WERE BEATING
REGULARLY WITH ALL THE PARTNERS
HERE WERE ABLE TO TRACK WHO'S
DOING WHAT HOW MUCH WILL BE ABLE
TO SEE IN THE DATA THAT'S
RETURNED TO US.
A PARTICULARLY QUICKLY WITH THE
ONLINE APPLICATIONS -- THE OUT
REACH A SISTER SARAH AND THE
APPLICATION OF SISTERS.
HAVE THEIR OWN UNIQUE CODE SO WE
CAN SEE WHO'S PRODUCING HOW MANY
APPLICATIONS WE WILL BE ABLE TO
TRACK ALL OF THAT INFORMATION
AND BE ABLE TO ADJUST IN REALITY
IF.
YOU'RE COLLECTING THE DATA SO
THAT THERE IS ONLY SO YOU'RE THE
ONE THAT'S COLLECTING ALARMING
OFFICIAL SERVICES OPERATES THE
CONFERENCE PROGRAM THIS IS OUR
STONE.
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY CELLS ALL I
JUST WANTED YES I WANT TO COME
BACK NEXT YEAR AND WE'RE HAVING
A DIFFERENT CONVERSATIONS I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
SO SO ALL OF THESE FOLKS YOU
HAVE DATES -- WHO'S DOING WHITE
BUT YOU'RE COOLEY ELECTING THAT
INFORMATION IN ASSURING THAT
WHOEVER'S IN CHARGE OF WHATEVER
IT IS IT IS FALLING THROUGH AND
MAKING IT HAPPENED WERE
ABSOLUTELY THE CENTRAL
REPOSITORY FOR ALL OF THAT WERE
ULTIMATELY ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
PROGRAM AND AS MISTER BUCKLEY
AND OTHERS HAVE STATED THIS.
HAS BEEN A PHENOMENAL
PARTNERSHIP WE CLEARLY CAN'T DO
THIS ALONE.
COUNTIES OTHER STATE AGENCIES
LOTS OF NON PROFITS.
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS IS
DOING OUR INDIVIDUAL TRAINING
WITH SOME OF THE LOCAL PARTNERS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
EVERYBODY'S GOT EVERYBODY ELSE'S
CONTACT INFORMATION IT'S A TEAM
EFFORT CERTAINLY THE BUCK STOPS
HERE OKAY PERFECT NOW AND THE
AND I IT JUST YOU KNOW.
I DON'T THINK I DON'T WANT TO
SOUND SKEPTICAL BUT IT'S SUCH A
BIG TASK THAT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE WE'RE FOLLOWING
THROUGH WITH WHAT WE WERE WHAT
THE INTENT TO AS AND THAT
SOMEBODY IS CHECKING ON THAT SO
THAT.
NOTHING FALLS THROUGH THE CRACKS
WE ARE HUGELY COMMITTED AND
WE'RE ALSO UNDER NO ILLUSIONS
THAT IT WILL GO PERFECTLY.
AND ALSO PREPARED TO ADJUST AT
AND DO WHAT WE NEED TO TO MAKE
IT AS A SIGN OF THIS LIST SO YOU
KNOW I DON'T EXPECT THAT TO GO
PERFECTLY EITHER I THINK YOU
KNOW WITH SOMETHING AS
COMPLICATED IS THAT SOMETHING IS
GOING TO HAPPEN AND YOU KNOW I'M.
GOOD WITH THAT AS LONG AS
SOMEBODY IS IN CHARGE AND YOU
KNOW AND IF SOMETHING DOES FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS PLEASE
IMMEDIATELY -- LET US KNOW ALSO
THAT WE'RE AWARE INSTEAD OF YOU
KNOW COMING BACK AND FINDING OUT
LATER BECAUSE WE'RE ALL
COMMITTED TO MAKING IT WORK.
AND SOUL IF THERE'S ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE COMMUNICATE IMMEDIATELY
AND NOT.
YOU KNOW IN A FEW MONTHS OUR
NEXT YEAR WE JUST WANNA KNOW
IMMEDIATELY SO THAT WE'RE ALL
AWARE WHEN WE GET QUESTIONS WE
CAN ASSURE THEM THAT IT'S BEEN
TAKEN CARE OF YES ABSOLUTELY AND
APPRECIATE THE OFFER.
MARATHON ON ALL TEAM ON THIS ONE
THANK YOU.
I WILL SAY THAT TO ALONG THOSE
LINES AND PAGE.
THIRTY SEVEN IS THE LANGUAGE WE
WILL BE APPROVING SPECIFICALLY
ON THIS I APPRECIATE THE DDS.
SAYS.
DSS RATHER -- SAYS THAT THE BUCK
STOPS HERE AND THERE UNDER GREAT
LEADERSHIP -- BUT IT IT WITH THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE'RE INCLUDING.
WHATEVER IS FOUND WILL BE
REPORTED TO THE LEGISLATURE SO
THAT TOGETHER WE CAN THEN TACKLE
IN THE ISSUES THAT DO COME UP.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS MISS
RUBIO -- THOSE ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
DOCTOR WOULD.
YEAH I JUST A QUESTION UNDER --
ITEM OF SECTION EIGHT THE
FEDERAL TITLE THREE FUNDING
AUGMENTATION SO IS THIS A NORMAL
THING WHERE YOU GET OCCASIONALLY
GET ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING
AND WHAT'S.
IS THIS THE CORRECT ONE YEAH I'M
I'M JUST CURIOUS HOW THIS COMES
IN AND RIGHT SO THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THIS IS INCLUDING THE
LAST -- BUDGET IN FEDERAL BUDGET
ACT -- THEY WILL YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES THE WORDS OR
NEGOTIATIONS -- FOR YOU KNOW
AUGMENTATIONS TO THE TITLE FREE
PROGRAM SO IN ON THE LAST
MEMORANDUM NEGOTIATIONS AN
ADDITIONAL SEVENTEEN MILLION WAS
ADDED.
WELL I SHOULD SAY THAT WAS
CALIFORNIA'S PORTION TO THE TO
THE FEDERAL BUDGET.
AND THEN -- IN ITS -- THAT IT
SPECIFICALLY ALLOCATED TO THOSE
DIFFERENT POSITIONS OR IS THAT
SOMETHING WAS DECIDED INTERNALLY --
OKAY SO FOR THE STATE OPERATIONS
COMPONENT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT LOOKS OUT
CALIFORNIA PART OF AGING WE LOOK
AT WHAT NECESSARY SUPPORTS OUR
RESOURCES WE NEED -- TO REMAIN
IN COMPLIANCE AND PROVIDE PROPER
MOUNT MONITORING AND OVERSIGHT
OF OUR TRIPLE A MONTH --
PARTNERS TO RECEIVE THE GRANT
FUNDS SO THAT IS A DEPARTMENT OF
TERMINATION IN TERMS OF WHERE WE
NEED TO ALLOCATE RESOURCES.
I GUESS I GUESS YEAH HI -- I
KNOW THAT THERE WAS A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT ASK AROUND THE LONG
TERM LONG TERM CARE OB -- BUT
YEAH.
SO I KNOW SAID THAT.
I THINK IT'S A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS -- YEAH.
HUNDRED SIXTEEN THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN THAT'S A FAR CRY FROM
THE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
ON THE OTHER END OF THE ASK SO --
CLEARLY WE HAVE A DIFFERENCE OF
WHAT'S IMPORTANT AND AND A LOT
OF ARMED AND JUST SAID I'M SORRY
JUST TO CLARIFY AS SPEAKING TO
THE STATE OPERATIONS COMPONENT
WHICH IS A SMALLER COMPONENT.
IN THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE
COMPONENT WHICH IS THE LARGER --
PORTION OF ASK THAT IS
DETERMINED THROUGH WHAT WE CALL
OUR INTERSTATE FUNDING FORMULA
SO KIND OF ALLOCATES.
DIFFERENT PERCENT OF THE FUNDING
YOU HAD TO THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH. TO MOVE
TO ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO POSTER YOUTH TROHMAN FORM
SYSTEMS OF CARE.
UNDER DDS YES.
LET'S START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
BRIAN WHEN FEEL WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND I HAVE WITH ME HERE
TODAY DOCTOR LEE AND CHRISTIAN
WHO IS OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
COMMITTEE SERVICES DIVISION.
AND TODAY WE'RE HERE TO PRESENT
ON THE GOVERNOR SPRING FINANCE
LETTER ON TRAUMA INFORMED
SYSTEMS OF CARE FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
THE DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY SERVES
APPROXIMATELY FIVE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS IN THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM WHO ALSO
ARE -- COURT DEPENDENT YOUTH IN
THE SYSTEM.
THE REQUESTED WE HAVE BEFORE YOU
TODAY IS FOR A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT THOUSAND TOTAL FUNDS
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY TO FUND
ONE POSITION AT THE DEPARTMENT.
AND ONE POINT SIX MILLION TOTAL
FUNDS ONE POINT ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR REGIONAL CENTER
OPERATIONS TO FIND.
FIFTEEN REGIONAL CENTER
POSITIONS -- FOR TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM ON BOTH OF THOSE.
THE INTENT OF AB TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE YEARS TO DEVELOP A
COORDINATED TIMELY AND TRAUMA
AND FORM SYSTEM OF CARE APPROACH
FOR FOSTER CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED TRAUMA?
A. B. TWENTY THREE REQUIRES THE
COUNTIES TO DEVELOP TIME
MEMORANDUMS OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH INVOLVED AGENCIES TO LAY
OUT THE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF EACH OF THE
AGENCIES ARE INVOLVED WITH THESE
HUGE.
AND TO WORK TOWARDS RESOLUTION
OF SERVICE PROVISION.
THE SECRETARY OF HUMAN HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY HAS
BEEN REQUIRED.
TO BRING TOGETHER THE
DEPARTMENTS AND TO DEVELOP A
JOINT INTERAGENCY RESOLUTION
TEAM AND THAT WORK HAS ALREADY
BEGUN AND THE AGENCY HAS BROUGHT
TOGETHER THAT DIRECTORS OF THE
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
INVOLVED.
AS WELL AS KEY STAFF TO DEVELOP
THIS -- INTERAGENCY RESOLUTION
TEAM AND AND OUR CHARTER
THE CHARTER WILL PROMOTE
COLLABORATION AND COMMUNICATION
ACROSS THE SYSTEMS OF CARE AND
SUPPORT TIMELY ACCESS TO AN
IMPORTANT SERVICES THAT ARE
NEEDED FOR THE YOUTH.
AND AS WELL PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WHEN NEEDED.
FROM THE THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THE WORKLOAD THAT IS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS FOR THE DEPARTMENT AND
HAS TO DO WITH -- DEVELOPMENT OF
GUIDANCE TO THE COUNTIES WITH
REGARDS TO THE MO USE THAT THEY
WILL ENTER INTO.
THEIR PARTICIPATION IN THE
PROCESS OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE --
DEVELOPMENT OF NEEDED RESOURCES
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
TIMELY SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS
AS WELL AS LOOKING AT WHAT IS
OUR MULTI LEVEL MULTI YEAR
APPROACH TO THOSE GAPS IN
SERVICES THAT WE NEED TO WORK TO
TO FIX. FOR THE REGIONAL CENTERS
THEY OF COURSE WILL HAVE LOCAL
LEVEL PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COUNTIES AND OTHER AGENCIES.
THEY WILL WORK TOWARDS --
PROVIDING INFORMATION AND
REFERRALS AND TO INSURE THAT
THERE IS A TIMELY COORDINATION
OF SERVICES THEY WILL BE
REPORTING ON SOME OF THE GAPS
AND AND SERVICES SO THAT WE AT
THE STATE LEVEL CAN THEN BEGIN
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT.
THAT ARE HAPPENING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
SO THAT'S THE THE REQUESTED FOR
YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
[inaudible]
NET NOT.
STEPHEN PUBLIC DEPARTMENT
FINANCING OF AN ASSET.
CHECK YOUR BRASSIERE ELIA WE
REVIEWED THE PROPOSAL AND HAVE
NO CONCERNS.
HER GET.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO DANIEL SABINO ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENTS
RECOGNITION OF THE ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD THAT THIS WILL REQUIRE.
AND THE FUNDING THAT COMES ALONG
WITH THAT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING TO BETTER ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THIS POPULATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SING NO MORE PUBLIC COMMENTS
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS YES MOST
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR THIS PROPOSAL AS FAR AS
UNDERSTANDING THAT OUR FOSTER
CHILDREN HAVE A DESPERATE NEED
WINTERS TRAUMA -- I'M MY CONCERN
IS THAT AGAIN -- WE HAVE SUCH AN
BASED ON THE RATE STUDY IN.
HAS BEEN ACCOMPLISHED IN MARCH.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A SHORTFALL OF
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
OF FUNDING FOR THE ID
DEPOPULATION [inaudible]
WE OF UTILIZED THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AS OUR STAFF HAS STOP
GAP. FOR EVERYTHING THAT.
AND THE INSURERS WON'T DO. FOR
THE ID POPULATION WE HAVE
CASELOADS FULLER SERVICE
COORDINATORS -- SUMMER. NINETY
THREE TO ONE EVEN OVER A HUNDRED
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE -- BUT
WE'VE ALREADY TAXED.
THESE REGIONAL CENTERS WITH A
LOT OF RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND THAT WERE NOT SHORT CHANGING
THIS POPULATION.
OF BECAUSE IT'S JUST THE ONLY
PLACE WE CAN GO -- I HAVE
WAITING LISTS.
OVER OVER A YEAR.
FOR PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND THEY'RE NOT GETTING SERVICES
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PROVIDERS.
WHAT ASSURANCES DO YOU GIVE ME
THAT YOU HAVE THE?
ABILITY TO MAKE SURE THE
REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE THE
PROVIDERS.
THAT WE CAN'T GIVE TO THE PEOPLE
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE IN IN THE
SYSTEM.
AND WE'RE GONNA NOW ADD MORE.
RESPONSIBILITY AND NEED. FOR
THESE FOSTER SHOWN WHO'S
SUFFERED FROM BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT THEM GOING IN THERE.
AND I WILL NOT ACCEPT A WAITING
LIST IN THIS SITUATION.
SO HOW DO YOU ASSURE ME THAT.
THIS IS A RESPONSIBILITY THAT
REGIONAL CENTERS CURRENTLY HAVE
CHIU INSURER -- TIMELY ACCESS TO
SERVICES AND TO COORDINATE WITH
A SISTER DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES AND SO I BELIEVE THAT
THROUGH THIS EFFORT.
AND THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
WITH THE ACROSS THE DEPARTMENTS
AS WELL AS THE FUNDING FOR THE
POSITIONS FOR THE REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT ARE LOW IT ALLOWS
US.
THAT.
BROADER VIEW IF YOU WILL AND THE
FOCUSED-- RESOURCES TO REALLY
WORK MORE CLOSELY TOGETHER TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE ARE THOSE GAPS
SOMETIMES THE GAPS ARE JUST AN
INFORMATION YOU KNOW SO COMING
TOGETHER AND SHARING WHAT'S
AVAILABLE IN IN VARIOUS PARTS OF
THE STATE.
WHAT'S ON SERVICES MIGHT MEET A
PARTICULAR NEED ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WITH REGARDS TO MAYBE
CRISIS SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE AND
SO I DO BELIEVE THAT THROUGH
THIS EFFORT -- IT WILL IMPROVE
THE SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE TO
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ARE YOU
TO PLAN WHO HAVE SUSTAIN TRAUMA.
SO WE ALREADY HAVE OTHER ISSUES
SOLANO COUNTY IS ONE OF MY OF
COUNTIES IN MY DISTRICT.
WE DON'T HAVE A PEDIATRIC TRAUMA
CRISIS SITUATION -- BEDS
[inaudible]
THERE'S NOT.
SO.
IF GOLDEN GATE.
WERE ABLE.
TO THERE'S NO WITH NO ORDER
REFER.
TO THERE'S NOT A PEDIATRIC
[inaudible]
CRISIS BUT SO.
I THINK THAT I'M SAYING IS.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESSES
IN IN A DIFFERENT FASHION WE
DON'T HAVE THE CAPABILITIES.
IN THE PROVIDER MODEL.
YOU CAN DO IT ADMINISTRATIVELY
ALL DAY LONG WHO.
BUT I'M GOING OUT AND HITTING
THE WEEDS IN TALKING TO THE
PROVIDERS THERE IS AN ABSOLUTE
BLACK.
CAN SO IF YOU TAKE HIS
RESPONSIBILITY GOTTA TELL ME
THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISH
THE MISSION.
BECAUSE THIS ONE COUNTY NOT
GOING.
TO THEY DON'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY.
YOU'RE GONNA GO TO NORTH BAY
REGIONAL NORTH BAY HOSPITAL.
AND YOU GONNA GET A FIFTY ONE
FIFTY IF BEST FOR SEVENTY TWO
HOURS.
AND IF FAN THAT -- EXPIRES THEN
YOU CAN GO TO JUVENILE HALL.
HOW DOES THIS FIX THAT?
WELL I DON'T KNOW THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE FIX ALL THE
PROBLEMS IN THE SYSTEM THROUGH
THIS EFFORT HOWEVER I DO BELIEVE.
THAT THROUGH THE VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS COMING TOGETHER TO
TALK ABOUT WHERE THEIR
BREAKDOWNS IN COMMUNICATION
WHERE THERE ARE -- GAPS IN THE
SERVICES WHERE WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO RESOLVE THESE ISSUES
AND BY US IDENTIFYING WHAT THOSE
ISSUES ARE FIRST OF ALL I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN PROVIDE.
MORE EXPEDIENT AND BETTER
SERVICES TO TO THESE INDIVIDUALS.
I APPRECIATE YOUR ENTHUSIASM.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT.
AND I HAD A BILL I THINK WAS
LAST YEAR THE YEAR BEFORE THAT
ACTUALLY WAS GOING TO REQUIRE
ALL THESE AGENCIES TO TALK.
AND IT WAS NOT SUPPORTED -- AND
I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE ADVANCING
THAT NOW.
IN A BIT THE COMMUNICATION IS
KEY RIGHT -- GOOD TO JUST
UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THE SERVICES AREN'T OUT THERE.
I AM THE GRASSROOTS LEVEL.
WE KNOW THAT JUST IN THE ID
POPULATION WITH THE WAITING LIST.
FOR SEVERELY.
DISABLED CHILDREN OR ADULTS.
WE CAN'T GET THEM HELP.
SO I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
ADDRESS THE PROVIDER ISSUE.
AND MAKING SURE THAT.
GRASS ROOTS IN THE ON THE FIRST
PRIORITY OF ALL OF THESE
AGENCIES.
IS MAKING SURE THANK YOU CAN TO
WHICH YOU.
ARE SETTING OUT TO ACCOMPLISH
WITH.
THE PEOPLE THAT NEED TO BE ABLE.
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE.
THERE'S A HUGE DISPARITY IN NY
BECAUSE A WE DON'T PAY ENOUGH.
HEY JOE SHOW THE RATE STUDY THAT
WE PROVIDED ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS OF THE DEFICIT.
UNDER FUNDING THAT POPULATION.
SO WHY WOULD ANYBODY WANT TO GET
INTO INVOLVED WITH THIS IF WE'RE
NOT FUNDING SO.
WE DO NOT HAVE A BACKUP OF
CONVERSATION BUT I REALLY I
REALLY NEED TO SEE.
FROM A GRASSROOTS PERSPECTIVE
THE YOU INCREASE.
THE EFFORTS ON PROVIDERS WHAT
ONE OF THE AND TYPES OF SERVICES
THAT IS VERY SUSTAINABLE ARE OUR
COMMITTEE CRISIS HOMES BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT RATE MODEL
AND THIS YEAR WE ARE PROPOSING.
TO EXTEND THOSE TWO CHILDREN AND
WE ALSO ARE EXPANDING OUR
SERVICES TO CHILDREN WITH
REGARDS TO THE STATE OPERATED
ACUTE CRISIS SERVICES.
WE HAVE OUR MOBILE CRISIS
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE SO
WE ARE CONTINUING TO LOOK AT
WHERE THOSE GAPS ARE AND WHAT
ADICIONAL MODELS WE NEED TO
CREATE TO MEET THOSE NEEDS.
SHE THAT BUT AND WHEN WE LOOK AT
WE ARE NOT.
COMPLYING WITH FEDERAL LAW.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT ACKNOWLEDGING
THE WAITING LIST THAT ARE OUT
THERE [inaudible]
AND SERIOUSLY WE I MEAN.
I DON'T WANT ANYBODY WAITING A
YEAR OR YEAR AND A HALF FOR ABA
OR YOU KNOW SOMETHING DUE TO
THEIR ASSESSMENT.
IT'S OUT THERE IT'S REAL.
BUT THE AGENCIES NOT FOR NOT
RESPONDING TO THAT BY GETTING
MORE PROVIDERS AND IF THIS.
IS IT ANOTHER ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT.
THESE AGENCIES THAT ARE CLOSE TO
COLLABORATE.
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT IS AN ISSUE
[inaudible]
AGREED.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
I THINK THAT THAT YOU KNOW.
OKAY WHO WAS A DENTAL THERE I
THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT
THE IN DEVELOPING THESE I'M --
USE OF IT AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE OTHER AGENCIES ARE INCLUDED
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING.
IN RESPONSE TO AB TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE I THINK RECOGNIZING THE
CONCERNS OF MEMBERS.
WHEN THOSE AND WILL USE TO PUT
TOGETHER TO BE SURE THAT ALL OF
THOSE ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED?
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ARE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED AS
FOLLOWS UNLESS THERE'S ANY
REQUEST FROM A MEMBER TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE GROUP OF VOTES.
WE WILL VOTERS FOLLOWS.
THE FIRST BUT WILL BE ON ALL
RECOMMENDATIONS AN ISSUE EIGHT
WHICH STARTS AT PAGE TWELVE THE
AGENDA WITH THE EXCEPTIONS OF
LINES. FIFTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE AND THIRTY SIX TO REPEAT
WERE VOTING ON ALL OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ITEMS ONE
THROUGH.
FIFTY SIX IN ISSUE EIGHT WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF FOUR OF THESE
LINES FIFTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE AND THIRTY SIX WHICH WILL
BE VOTING ON SEPARATELY.
SO FIVE TOTAL VOTES WILL OCCUR
ONE FOR THE GROUP AND THEN FOR
INDIVIDUAL VOTES FOR THE LINES I
HAVE REFERENCED.
SO FOR THE FIRST VOTE I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK FOR A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THE AGENDA FOR ALL ISSUES WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF FIFTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE AND THIRTY
SIX I DO WANT TO ADD THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE REQUEST ASSISTANCE
FROM THE LA -- IN DRAFTING
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE FOR LINE.
SEVEN AND WE KNOW THAT WE ASK
FOR THE LA OWES ASSISTANCE.
IN PARTICULAR WITH OTHER ACTIONS
AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR
LINE SEVEN IT IS NOT EXPLICITLY
STATED IN THE ACTION I WANT TO
BE SURE WE MAKE THE FORMAL
REQUEST -- WE'LL DO THAT IN JUST
A MOMENT SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND -- FOR ISSUE EIGHT ALL
EXCEPT THOSE FOUR ITEMS PLEASE
TAKE VOTE.
MISS REYES HI FRAZIER.
MATHIS -- SIN RAMOS RUBIO.
WOOD [inaudible]
HAS.
FIVE RED FOR LINE.
SEVEN AS I NOTED IT'S NOT
EXPLICITLY STATED SO TO HAVE A
MOTION TO APPROVE THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU.
FIFTEEN SYSTEM.
ONLY [inaudible]
THIRTY THREE YEAH.
THE TO THE SECOND OF THE TWO
ZERO ALL RIGHT FOR THE SECOND
VOTE OUR MOTION TO APPROVE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR LINE FIFTEEN
OF ISSUE.
EIGHT REYES I FRAZIER MATHIS
PATTERSON RAMOS RUBIO.
DOCTOR WOULDN'T.
HAS [inaudible]
FIVE THANK.
THE WHOLE THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ON LINE NINETEEN OF ISSUE.
EIGHT A BEFORE I TAKE THE MOTION
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE LA DOES
HELP -- IN DRAFTING THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO BE SHARED.
SOON WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT ACCOMPLISHES.
THIS ACTION ON CAL WORKS GRANTS.
IS THAT AGREEABLE.
VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT SIR CAN I
HAVE A MOTION.
THANK YOU THAT'S ONLINE EIGHTEEN
OF ISSUE EIGHT WE'VE MOTIONS
SECOND. NINETEEN ONLINE NINETEEN
OF ISSUE EIGHT THANK YOU.
REYES I FRAZIER.
MATHIS.
PATTERSON RAMOS RUBIO.
DOCTOR WOULD.
HAS.
FIVE THANK YOU WILL LEAVE THAT
OPEN AS WELL.
CAN I GET THAT EMOTION ONLINE
TWENTY THREE OF ISSUE.
EIGHT STICK THE ROLE.
AS I FRAZIER.
AT THIS SO [inaudible]
PATTERSON RAMOS RUBIO.
WOOD.
HAS.
FOR THANK YOU AND FINALLY A
MOTION TO APPROVE
RECOMMENDATIONS LINE THIRTY SIX
OF ISSUE [inaudible] EIGHT FOR
PLEASE TAKE THE WHEEL.
REYES I FRAZIER MATHIS NO
[inaudible]
PATTERSON RAMOS RUBIO
DOCTOR WOULD [inaudible]
HAS.
FOR THANK YOU.
AGAIN WILL LEAVE THAT THE ISSUE
OPEN LEAVE THAT ITEM OPEN.
A GOOD THAT LET'S GO TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
THREE THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION.
LET'S START WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS IRENE WILL LAY
LE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
FOR THE INDEPENDENT LIVING IN
COMMUNITY ACCESS DIVISION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ON THE REQUEST FOR
FUNDING.
OF FOR THE CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
SHOUT REACH VIA THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS.
THIS PROPOSAL IS LABELED LABELED
SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY INCOME SSI
CASH OUT REVERSAL IMPLEMENTATION
VIA THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS.
THE PROPOSAL REQUESTS AN
INCREASE OF TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION.
IN REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY FOR
THE FISCAL YEAR. NINETEEN TWENTY
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION.
THE FUNDING IS TO ASSIST THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
STATE'S CALPERS EXPANSION
PROGRAM.
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
WILL REIMBURSE THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION. FOR THE COSTS OF
PRE SCREENING HI TOUCH
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE.
FOLLOW UP DATA COLLECTION AND
THE RELATED CONTRACT
ADMINISTRATION.
OF FOR THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS TO PROVIDE LOCALLY
THROUGH JUNE.
THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAD REQUESTED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION AS
THE DESIGNATED STATE ENTITY
ADMINISTERING STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDS TO THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS.
WORK LOCALLY THROUGH THE TWENTY
EIGHT INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS.
ARE. TO ASSIST IN EXPANDING THE
CALPERS BENEFITS IN -- TO
IMPLEMENT THE THEY CASH OUT
REVERSAL THAT WAS PASSED IN A.
B. -- L. A. B. AB.
EIGHTEEN ELEVEN THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS WILL WORK WITH
THEIR CURRENT -- CONSUMERS
APPROXIMATELY 80% OF WHOM ARE SS
I SS P. RECIPIENTS AND THEY WILL
WORK WITH THEM TO CONDUCT PRE
SCREENING BOTH PAPER AND
ELECTRONIC. TO DETERMINE IF THEY
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE LIKELY
ELIGIBLE FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN THEY WOULD PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY APPLICATION ASSISTANCE
FOR EACH PERSON'S SITUATION.
WHETHER THAT BE -- WORKING WITH
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR THEIR
DISABILITIES OR LIMITATIONS
EXPERIENCED BY OLDER ADULTS.
WHO ARE ALSO COMING TO THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS?
SO THEY CAN SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETE THOSE APPLICATIONS.
AND ACHIEVE APPROVAL.
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS -- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR DATA IS
COLLECTED APPROPRIATELY THROUGH
THE ELECTRONIC PORTALS THAT A
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
IT HAS MENTIONED -- PREVIOUSLY
THERE ARE UNIQUE IDENTIFIERS FOR
ALL OF THE COUNTY PORTALS SO
THAT THOSE -- WILL BE TRACKED
AND WE WILL HAVE GOOD --
PERFORMANCE DATA ON THE RESULTS
OF THE WORK OF THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS WITH THEIR THEIR
LOCAL POPULATIONS -- THEY WILL
BE RESPONSIBLE -- ONCE THE
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENTS AGO GREEN
MEANT AND CONTRACTS ARE IN PLACE.
TO CONTACT THEIR CURRENT
CONSUMERS DO THE PRE SCREENING.
PROVIDE THE APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE AND FOLLOW UP ON THE
APPROVAL RATE -- AND THEN
PROVIDE MONTHLY AS WELL AS
QUARTERLY REPORTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND THE DEPARTMENT IS IN TURN
RESPONSIBLE FOR REPORTING TO
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES --
WE HAVE.
SET UP OF A SYSTEM.
FOR ONGOING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS.
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE
COORDINATED OF COURSE WITH THE
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES HAS MENTIONED.
THAT WILL ALSO BE PROVIDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION AS
THE PRIME CONTRACTORS.
WITH THE TECHNICAL INFORMATION
TO SUPPORT SUCCESSFUL
APPLICATIONS.
OUR GOAL IS.
TO WORK WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO ARE ALREADY --
TRUSTED PARTNERS WITH THE LOCALS
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS.
SO THAT THEY CAN ACHIEVE SUCCESS
IN GETTING THESE FOOD BENEFITS
WHICH WILL BE VERY HELPFUL TO
THEM -- AS IN THEIR STATUS AS SS
I SS P. RECIPIENTS.
OF COURSE WE WILL BE
PARTICIPATING IN THE ON GOING --
CALLS AND MEETINGS THAT
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES IS
HAVING AS WELL AS THEIR
TRAININGS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD BANKS.
ARE THAT WILL BE BOTH IN PERSON
AND WEBINARS AND THEN WE IN TURN
WILL CONDUCT BOTH IN PERSON.
AND WEB IN OUR AND READ OUT.
ON ON DEMAND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS.
AS WELL AS MONTHLY
TELECONFERENCES WITH THE CENTERS
SO THAT THEY CAN ASK QUESTIONS --
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS.
WE SET SET THIS UP THIS WAY
BECAUSE IT IS TIME LIMITED --
AND WE WANT TO ACHIEVE THE
GREATEST -- IMPACT POSSIBLE WITH
THIS POPULATION -- I'M HAPPY --
TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE IN THE AGENDA -- OKAY.
YS PLEASE OKAY.
THE FIRST QUESTION -- HOW WILL --
AGENT AT DEPARTMENT OF AGING
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION AND
OTHER AFFECTED AGENCIES.
TRANSMITTING FORMATION
OBSERVATION SUGGESTIONS FOR
PROBLEM SOLVING BACK TO DSS.
WHAT PROTOCOLS ARE IN PLACE OR
WILL BE TO ASSURE CROSS
DEPARTMENTAL COMMUNICATION?
TOWARDS THE STRONG THIS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
INITIATIVE POSSIBLE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES CAL FRESH OUTREACH TEAM
HAS CONVENED ALL OF THE OF
CONTRACTORS AND THE SISTERS OF
THAT.
ARE WORKING ON THIS PROGRAM
INCLUDING DEPARTMENT OF AGING
AND DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
AS WELL AS DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
ON THAT FIRST MEETING WAS HELD
APRIL TWENTY FIFTH.
OF THIS MONTH WE WILL START THE
GROUP MEETINGS THAT WILL BE.
DODD CALLED CALPERS CONNECTS
WITH DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDED WITH A
RESOURCE DOCUMENT THAT LISTS ALL
THE LOCAL CONTACTS -- FOR THE
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENTS.
OF THE LOCAL AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING.
THE INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS --
AS WELL AS DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION CONTACTS AND
REGIONAL CENTERS.
AND THAT IS TO FACILITATE ON THE
GROUND -- COLLABORATION -- WE
HAVE ALREADY BEGUN WORK WITH THE
CENTERS TO ESTABLISH CONTACTS
WITH THEIR LOCAL COUNTIES --
USING THIS RESOURCE -- THE
INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENT TRAININGS
ARE GOING TO BEGIN.
THE PLANNING PROCESS A WELL THEY
BEGAN THE PLANNING PROCESS THIS
MORNING.
AND WE HAVE A FOLLOW UP A
CONSULTATION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD BANK ASSOCIATION.
WHO ARE THE -- TRAINERS THAT
WILL BE PROVIDING US THE
TRAINING.
AND WE'VE DISCUSSED STAR.
OF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
ACCOMMODATIONS SO THAT THE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
APPROPRIATELY.
ODD SERVED AND TRAINED -- THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS HAVE
AT LEAST 51% OF THEIR EMPLOYEES
ARE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
SO THAT IS.
THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION.
THOSE TRANCES WILL BEGIN IN --
THE WEBINARS THIS WILL BEGIN IN
JULY OR AUGUST -- THE WEBINARS
WILL BE ARCHIVED SO THAT THEY
CAN BE ACCESSED AT ANY TIME.
IN ADDITION OUR DEPARTMENT WILL
COOPERATE COLLABORATE AND SHARE
ANY RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE
DEVELOPED SPECIFICALLY. FOR
WORKING WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES -- WE OFFERED THOSE --
ACTUALLY THIS MORNING -- TO THE
GROUP AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THOSE.
THE ALSO -- DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES WILL BE TRACKING THE
VOLUME AND THE RESULTS OF ALL
THE APPLICATIONS BOTH ONLINE AND
PAPER.
AND THEY WILL BE TRACKING THOSE
ACCORDING TO THEIR SOURCE SO
WHOEVER THE APPLICATIONS THE
SISTERS ARE.
WILL BE IDENTIFIED.
SO WE WILL HAVE -- THAT DATA
SHARED WITH CDSS MONTHLY --
QUARTERLY WILL PROVIDE A WRITTEN
REPORT -- THIS WILL BE SHARED
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS THROUGH
THEIR DASHBOARD [inaudible]
AND THAT'S THE SECOND QUESTION.
IS CAN THE ADMINISTRATION PLEASE
PROVIDE AN ITEMS.
SORRY I'M SECOND QUESTION YOU'VE
SEEN THE HANDOUTS OKAY.
AND THAT PROVIDES INFORMATION
YES IT DOES A VERY GOOD.
I WANT TO SAVE YOU FROM HAVING
TO READ AND AND DO TELL US AGAIN.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT ANY -- PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
I'M SORRY TO PUBLIC FINANCE UP
WHISPERED UPON THE FINANCE
NOTHING AT HAPPY ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
GOOD HELLO.
ALL RIGHT NOW PUBLIC COMMENT.
MADAM CHAIR AGAIN MY CAROL WITH
WESTERN CENTER LAW POVERTY THIS
AGAIN IS SOMETHING FOR
SUPPORTING AND CONSISTENT WITH
ALL THE WORK WE CAN DO WITH THAT
APARTMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
I THINK YOUR RESPONSE TO THE
FIRST QUESTION WAS VERY THOROUGH
AND I THINK THAT.
AND YOU'VE HEARD FROM OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S FEEDBACK MAKING SURE
THAT.
EVERYBODY IS IN THE LOOP SO THAT
WHEN THERE ARE ISSUES WITH THEIR
PROBLEMS.
THEY ARE RESOLVED QUICKLY RATHER
THAN WAITING UNTIL THE TIME IS
PASSED AND THOSE WHO SHOULD BE
RECEIVING SERVICES AREN'T
RECEIVING THEM.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE TO
THAT QUESTION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THANK YOU THIS CONCLUDES ITEM
ARE ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WHAT WE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE ITEMS HAVE
ALREADY VOTED ON THE FIRST VOTE
WAS.
FOR ALL ISSUES ALL LINES IN
ISSUE A WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
LINES FIFTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE AND THIRTY SIX MISTER
RAMOS.
MR ALMOST AYE HAS.
SIX THE SECOND VOTE IS FOR LINE
FIFTEEN OF ISSUE EIGHT MISTER
RAMOS.
STROKES AYE HAS SIX THE THIRD
VOTE WAS FOR LINE NINETEEN OF
ISSUE A MISTER RAMOS.
STRONG MOST I HAS.
SIX THE FOURTH VOTE WAS FOR LINE
TWENTY THREE OF ISSUE EIGHT
MISTER RAMOS.
MISTER ROEMER SITE HAS.
FIVE THE FIFTH PHùIN THE
FINAL VOTE WAS FOR LINE THIRTY
SIX OF ISSUE EIGHT MISTER RAMOS.
MR ALMOST I HAS FIVE ALL THE
MOTIONS HAVE PASSED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
FOUR DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR POPLAR
ACTING DIRECTOR OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
FEATURED BANKER CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR.
IN ORDER THE TAG TEAM A LITTLE
BIT HERE ALL SPEAK TO THE FIRST
ISSUE WHICH IS THAT --
INCREASING THE FREQUENCY OF
INSPECTIONS IN CHILD CARE HOMES
LAST YEAR IN THE BUDGET ACTION
ADOPTED BY THE LEGISLATURE SOME
OF THE GOVERNOR.
THE BUDGET INCLUDED TWENTY SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THIS YEAR AND FOR NEXT YEAR IN
ADDITIONAL CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT FUNDS
WERE CCD BG. TO DO ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS THIS REQUEST SIMPLY
PUTS THE POSITIONS TO GO WITH
THE DOLLARS -- THE CHILDCARE
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT IS A
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF CHANGES
ADOPTED TO THAT ABOUT THREE
YEARS AGO ONE OF WHICH REQUIRED
THE ANNUAL CHILD CARE LICENSING
WE HAD CURRENTLY BEEN ATTY EVERY
THREE YEAR INSPECTION FOR A
CHILD CARE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WHICH HAD INCREASED FROM JUST A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WHEN IT WAS
IT FIVE YEARS.
SAID THIS FUN THESE FUNDS WILL
GIVE US THE ADEQUATE RESOURCES
ALONG WITH THE POSITIONS TO BE
ABLE TO CONDUCT ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS AT ALL OF OUR CHILD
CARE FACILITIES WHICH ARE
APPROXIMATELY FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND IN THE STATE TODAY.
ON ISSUE NUMBER ARE WELL DONE
FOR B. HOW YEAH SAME ISSUE LEYVA
TRIP MYSELF SORRY -- HOUSING
TEAM IS IS PROUD TO OPERATE A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
VITAL SUPPORTS TO PEOPLE EITHER
SEEKING SSI BENEFITS TRYING TO
REUNITE OUT OF THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM WITH FAMILIES OR SIMPLY
TO STABILIZE THEIR THEIR
FAMILIES LIVING SITUATION AND
THE THREE PROGRAMS LISTED.
IN YOUR AGENDA.
BUT WE'RE NOW -- OPERATING
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND PROGRAMS -- IN THIS
VEIN AND WE'RE DOING THAT WITH
ONLY THIRTEEN PEOPLE ACROSS THIS
MANY PROGRAMS -- THAT THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFICULTY IN
OUR ABILITY TO ADEQUATELY
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND OVERSIGHT TO
THOSE PROGRAMS.
AND ONE OF THE POSITIONS THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS A RESEARCH
PROGRAM SPECIALIST TO ASSIST
WITH THE EVALUATION OF THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM --
WHICH IS SOMETHING I THINK THAT
WE'RE ALL INTERESTED IN SEEING.
AFTER A ROUGHLY AT THIS POINT
TWO AND A HALF YEARS OF
OPERATION -- SO.
LOOKING LOOKING FOR THAT THE
SUPPORT WE NEED TO TO DO RIGHT
BY THESE PROGRAMS AND MAKE THEM
AS EFFECTIVE AS THEY REALLY NEED
TO BE [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
THE THIRD ISSUE.
FISCAL.
COUNTY AND COUNTY OVERSIGHT OF
COUNTY OPERATIONS -- FOR THIS WE
ARE ASKING TO INCREASE OUR OUR
REIMBURSEMENTS AS WELL AS OUR
FUNDING FOR THIS TO GET FIVE NEW
POSITIONS DO FISCAL MANAGEMENT.
THIS CALL MONITORING AND
COUNTIES WE'VE CURRENTLY BEEN
UNDER DIRECTION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT WE ARE NOT DOING
ADEQUATE MONITORING OF OUR
COUNTY FISCAL OPERATIONS.
THESE ARE SIMILAR TO BUT NOT
EXACTLY AUDITS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF
THE FEDERAL FUNDING THAT'S
PASSED THROUGH THE STATE.
GOES DOWN THE LOCAL.
LEVEL IS BEING EXPENDED
CORRECTLY THEY WOULD LIKE US TO
MONITOR MORE AT BEING THESE FIVE
POSITIONS WILL ALLOW US TO
EXPAND THAT -- TO A LEVEL WHERE
THE FAITHFUL FIND IT ACCEPTABLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
SENATE HAMMER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING THAT AT THIS
TIME.
OUR WORDS PER MINUTE PLANTS
NOTHING ELSE TO ADD.
CHECK YOU ARE AFFECTING BEING
RIGHT EXACTLY.
CHECK A ROSIER ELIA WE REVIEWED
ALL THREE OF THE ITEMS NO MAJOR
CONCERNS -- WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT AND FINANCE ON A
TECHNICAL QUESTION ABOUT -- BE
AND WITH A SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD JUST LIKE FOR MEMBERS IS --
WHILE THE PROPOSAL IT FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR IS BEING FUNDED WITH
FEDERAL FUNDS THERE'S QUESTIONS
IN FUTURE YEARS WHETHER THOSE
FEDERAL FUNDS WILL BE AVAILABLE --
SUGGESTS MORE OF A A POINT OF A
POTENTIAL ISSUES IN THE FUTURE
OF HOW WE WOULD FUND THESE
POSITIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PUBLIC LET'S OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT NOW.
SAYING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER RAMOS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND AND THE MONITORING AND
OVERSIGHT THE COUNTY OPERATIONS
SAID HOW DO YOU ENVISION.
THAT -- TAKING PLACE.
WE CURRENTLY DO -- MONITORING
AND ALL OVER AND NOT WE DO
MONITORING ALL OF OUR CURRENT
FEDERAL PROGRAMS.
BUT WE ONLY MONITOR A FEW
COUNTIES HERE THIS WILL ALLOW US
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
COUNTIES THAT WE ARE THAT WE ARE
MONITORING EACH YEAR WE
BASICALLY GO IN AND TO DESK ON
ITS WILL RIPPLE ACTUAL FILES IN
THE COUNTY WE DON'T DO THIS FROM
SACRAMENTO.
WE GO DOWN TO VISIT COUNTIES IN
ORDER -- TO REVIEW THEIR
EXPENDITURES AND AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE CLAIMING IS DONE
APPROPRIATELY THAT THE PROPER
SERVICES ARE BEING PROVIDED AND
THAT ALL THE DOLLARS LINE UP
WITH WHAT WE HAVE ALLOCATED TO
THEM IN THE CURRENT YEAR SO IN
THAT.
TYPE OF A SIMPLE AUDITING OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES THAT ARE
THERE.
WHAT ARE THE PARAMETERS LARGE
COUNTIES URBAN COUNTY SERVICE
SUBURBAN -- IRVINE -- BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK IT'S A 100% FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES RIGHT IT'S YOU'RE
CHOOSING CERTAIN ONES -- TO LOOK
INTO THE OVERSIGHT THAT THEN
GIVES YOU THE THE SAMPLING OF
WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT WE WE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR FIRST SO
WE LOOK AT THE LARGER COUNTY USE --
BY AND LARGE BUT WE ALSO LIKE TO
LOOK AT THE SMALLER COUNTIES AS
WELL ALWAYS MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE SORT OF SMALL AND MEDIUM
COUNTIES INCLUDED AS WELL. TO
INSURE INSURE THAT THEY'RE DOING
IT AND PROVIDE THE MANY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NECESSARY
BECAUSE SOMETIMES IF THERE ARE
FEDERAL THIS ALLIANCE IS IN A
SMALL COUNTY IT ACTUALLY MATTERS --
YOU KNOW IT MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE FOR A SMALL COUNTY.
SO WE TRY TO HELP THEM BY DOING
IT MAY INCLUDING THEM AS WELL.
SO IN.
AN INCREASING -- THE OVERSIGHT
WE NOW GOING TO INCREASE THAT
SAMPLE POOL ALSO GET COUNTIES.
BY HOW MUCH.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS JUST SAYING
ABOUT HOW TO HEAR ON MY ON MY
SCREEN BECAUSE I HAD SOMETHING
EARLIER TODAY -- AND I'M.
OF COURSE HAD TOO MANY EMAILS
TODAY -- WAS.
ONE NINE REGRETTABLY NO -- TO
HELP.
OUT SEE IF THIS ONE HAS THE
NUMBER OF HOW MANY AUDITS WERE
DOING -- SIR -- THIS IS GOING TO
ALLOW US TO INCREASE OUR
CAPACITY -- TO FROM TH WE WERE
DOING -- FOR THIS WILL ALLOW US
TO DO SIX COUNTIES EACH FISCAL
YEAR -- AND IT ENSURES THAT WE
CAN HAVE A CYCLE WHERE EVERY
COUNTY WILL BE REVIEWED AT LEAST
EVERY TEN YEARS.
SPATTER.
GET TO THE FIFTY YES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WOW.
WITH THE FEDERAL FUNDS I I AM
VERY INTERESTED IN THE ADOPTION
STATUTORY CHANGES THAT CONFORM
AND REQUIRE ANNUAL.
INSPECTIONS FOR CHILD CARE
CENTERS AND FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOMES.
CAN I ASK ADMINISTRATIONS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
ARE IN A DRAFTING THIS LANGUAGE
IN PREPARATION FOR US TO ADOPT
THIS AFTER THE MAY REVISE CLOSE
OUT HEARING.
WONDERFUL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE QUESTIONS COME HIS RUBIO
JUST ON THE ANNUAL WEALTH --
THEM BACK UP ON THE WE DISCUSSED
THE THE TEMPER POSITIONS ARE.
MY CONCERN IS THAT.
YOU ARE CORRECT WE DON'T HAVE WE
CAN'T COUNT ON THE FEDERAL FUNDS
BY HOW DO YOU RECRUIT FOLKS --
IF THE POSITIONS ARE NOT GOING
TO BE -- I'M GOING WE ARE WE ARE
CURRENTLY HIRING PEOPLE IS
PERMANENT -- THERE ARE THERE ARE
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING PROGRAM --
WHICH IN MOST OF THESE POSITIONS
ARE NOT ALL OF THEM -- THE
PEOPLE WHO DO THE INSPECTIONS
THERE IS -- CONSIDERABLE
TURNOVER AND THAT'LL POPULATIONS
WERE HIRING THEM IS PERMANENT
WE'RE HOPING THAT THAT -- THE
FUNDING WILL CONTINUE BUT FOR
MISSION THERE IT TAKES CARE YES
PEOPLE RETIRE PEOPLE LEAVE -- SO
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE WON'T BE
ANY PROBLEM WITH IT ZORBING THAT
ENDED THOSE ADDITIONAL STAFF SO
WE ARE HARD TO MISS PERMANENT
POSITIONS OKAY SO THAT WE WON'T
HAVE THOSE ISSUES AND THEN I
KNOW WE'VE DISCUSSED THE ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS AND RIGHT NOW THERE
IT'S EVERY THREE YEARS -- WHAT'S
STOPPING US FROM DOING IT EVERY
SINGLE YEAR CHILD CARE SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE VERY CRITICAL
OBVIOUSLY AND IT'S A VERY
DANGEROUS -- WELL IT SAYS.
THE OVERSIGHT IS CRITICAL -- I
DID SEE THE RESULT I'M RUNNING A
BILL ON CHILD CARE SERVICES AND
THERE IS A PARENT THE CONTEST TO
FIND SAID THAT THERE WAS.
AN INCIDENT THAT HER SON'S --
DAYCARE OR CHILD CARE -- PLACE
AND HE END UP HOSPITALIZED AND
HEMORRHAGED IN YOU KNOW A LOT OF
ISSUES AND IF WE INSPECT EVERY
THREE YEARS.
YOU KNOW HOW IS THAT BEING
MONITORED I MEAN IN MY OPINION
IN OF THOSE POSITIONS LIKE --
THE OLD FOLKS.
HOMES SHOULD HAVE A REGULAR
VISIT JUST SO THAT WE ARE AWARE
OF ANY ISSUES BECAUSE THESE ARE.
YOUNG PEOPLE AND OLD PEOPLE NOT
YET AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING
OBVIOUSLY BUT MY POINT IS THAT
THESE ARE VULNERABLE KIDS AND
SOME OF THEM.
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO TO SPEAK SOUL
CAN WE TALK ABOUT POSSIBLY IN
THE FUTURE.
OR SOON SOONER RATHER THAN LATER
TO HAVE ANNUAL INSPECTIONS AS
OPPOSED TO EVERY -- COUPLE YEARS
WELL THANKFULLY THAT'S WHAT THAT
THAT FUNDING WILL PROVIDE IS IT
WILL BE ANNUAL FOR THE NEXT THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS AND BY
PUTTING ON IMPERIAL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S ASKING RIGHT BUT
IT'S TEMPORARY FIND NG.
AND SOUL CAN YOU HELP US BE
CREATIVE SO THAT.
THE WAY YOU'RE BEING CREATIVE
YOU KNOW AND AND USING THE
RESOURCES THAT YOU HAVE TO HIRE
THESE FOLKS HOW CAN WE LEVERAGE.
FINDING NOW TO MAKE THAT A
PERMANENT.
I ASIAN STEP ONLY FOR THE NEXT
FEW YEARS ONE OF THE THINGS THE
WORKING.
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN DOING AND COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS HAS BEEN REALLY TO REBUILD
THE FOUNDATION OF LICENSING.
AND TO WHICH HAD BEEN KIND OF
DECIMATED DURING THAT THE THAT
THE RECESSIONARY TIMES AND TO
TRY AND DEVELOP NEW WAYS OF
DOING BUSINESS THAT CAN MAKE US
MORE EFFICIENT AND STILL MORE --
FUNDING OR QUALITY -- WHEN WE'RE
DOING OUR INSPECTIONS SO WE'VE
DEVELOPED A NEW INSPECTION TOOL
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT'S
GOING TO ALLOW US TO DO A BETTER
MORE THOROUGH JOB WHEN WE'RE
DOING INSPECTIONS INSTEAD OF THE
WAY THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IT NOW --
WHICH IS A A FAIRLY SHORT KEY
INDICATOR TOOL WE'RE MOVING TO A
MORE IN DEPTH.
TOOL THAT ACTUALLY IF YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DRILL DOWN ON THE AREA MORE
THAT PROBLEM OCCURS A LOT MORE
MORE QUICKLY FOR HOPING THAT IT
THAT OVER TIME AS WE DEVELOPED
AND WE'RE JUST DEVELOPING THESE
TOOLS NOW.
THAT THAT WILL MAKE US MORE
EFFICIENT IN OUR ABILITY TO DO
IT THE MORE EFFICIENT THE WE CAN
BE THE MORE TIME WE FREE UP SO
IF THERE IS A POSSIBILITY THAT
WE CAN SEE THAT EFFICIENCY
ACTUALLY COMING TO FRUITION IN
SEVERAL YEARS.
THAT MIGHT HAVE SYSTEMS IN YOU
KNOW SORT OF FREEING UP
ADDITIONAL TIME TO DO MORE
INSPECTIONS -- IN ADDITIONALLY
YOU KNOW FOCUSING ON PROVIDING
QUALITY ASSISTANT OUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO PROVIDERS. TO HELP
THEM BE IN COMPLIANCE INSTEAD OF
HAVING TO SITE FOR ONCE
SOMETHING IS ALREADY GONE WRONG
WE'RE TRYING TO DO A LOT MORE IN
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO HELP THE COMPLIANCE.
THAT HELPS WITH HAVING FEWER
COMPLAINTS -- BECAUSE BY BEING
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE FACILITY
CAN RUN BETTER SO ALL OF THESE
THINGS OVER TIME SHOULD BE
ALLOWING US TO MAKE MORE
EFFICIENT USE OF OUR STAFF AND
THEREFORE HOPEFULLY HOPEFULLY.
BE ABLE TO CREATE SIMILAR TIME
FOR INSPECTIONS WILL IT BE THIS
MUCH THAT QUICKLY.
I DO I WOULD NOT AT ALL OVER
PROMISE THAT.
THANK YOU IF YOU KNOW IF WE
pCOULD BE AT ASSISTANCE OBVIOUSLY
TO DO THAT PLEASE LET US KNOW SO
THAT -- WE CAN SEE THIS AND
NOBODY'LL NOTICE THAT WE'RE
DOING IT EVERY YEAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- NO NO WE'LL JUST
KEEP IT QUIET JUST BETWEEN ALL
OF US HERE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
YOU MENTION CITATIONS AND
VIOLATIONS -- COULD YOU JUST FOR
INFORMATIONAL PURPOSES SHARE
WITH US WHAT YOUR COMPLAINT --
TOTAL IS AND ALSO WHEN YOU'RE
OUT WHAT YOUR CITATION OR
VIOLATION.
AVERAGES PER VISIT.
I CAN SPEAK TO THE AVERAGE PER
VISIT AND I CAN.
GIVE OUR CHILD CARE -- A PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR BEHIND ME WHO MAY
HAVE MORE SPECIFIC NUMBERS BUT
IN TERMS OF HOW MANY --
CITATIONS WE HAVE PER VISIT IT'S
RELATIVELY SMALL ACROSS ALL
PROGRAMS IT TENDS TO BE LESS
THAN TO ANY PARTICULAR VISIT IN
TIME.
NOW THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT A
PARTICULAR FACILITY MIGHT HELP
SEVERAL AND MY HAVE CERTAINLY
MORE SERIOUS VIOLATIONS -- THAN
OTHERS BUT WE DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF CITATIONS THAT ARE GIVEN OUT.
ONE THE REASON I'M JUST TRYING
TO VALIDATE THE THE ESSENTIAL
REASON FOR HAVING THESE
INSPECTIONS OF THE PROTECTION OF
THE CHILDREN AND AND THEN YOU
ARE FINDING.
IN EVERY INSTANCE SOMETHING THAT
WILL BENEFIT THE CHILD'S SAFETY
OR IT WILL BE ABSOLUTELY -- AND
I AND I DO AND I WHEN I SAY THAT
THE YOU KNOW.
THERE'S ONE OR TWO WHEN WE GIVE
FROM CITATIONS THERE'S TWO TYPES
OF CITATIONS WE TEND TO GET ONE
OR THINGS THAT ARE AN IMMEDIATE
RISK THOSE ARE CALLED TYPE A
MEANING IT'S THAT.
THAT CHILD RIGHT NOW IS AT RISK
OF SOMETHING HAPPENING.
THAN THE OTHERS IT'S A POTENTIAL
RISK IF YOU DON'T DO SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT THIS PROBLEM IS THEN
THAT CAN HAPPEN.
AND WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF THOSE TYPE A BIT VIOLATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN ANY
GIVEN YEAR -- IN ADDITION WE
DEAL WITH COMPLAINTS WHICH
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN AT SUCH AN
INFREQUENT -- INSPECTION --
INTERVALS DURING THE LAST DECADE
OR SO -- WE HAVE A BECOME TO
RELY MUCH MORE ON COMPLAINTS
WHEN PEOPLE CALL IN TO SAY HEY
SOMETHING'S GOING ON AT MY
CHILD'S CHILD CARE THIS INCIDENT
HAPPENED.
AND WE HAVE TO RESPOND TO THAT
AND SO IT IT ALL KIND OF IS IT
FITS TOGETHER IN ITS SYSTEM OF
OF MAKING SHORT ENSURING HEALTH
AND SAFETY SO.
THESE L. P. A.'S THAT LICENSING
PROGRAM ANALYSTS AT THAT DO
THESE INSPECTIONS THEY ALSO DO
ALL THAT OTHER WORK AND SO
PROVIDING -- FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO DO THESE ANNUAL INSPECTIONS
SHOULD HOPEFULLY ALSO AND IN
FEWER COMPLAINTS BECAUSE WE HAVE
BETTER COMPLIANCE AND SHE WERE
BAD THINGS HAPPENING THE WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS AFTER THE FACT.
DULY NOTED THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER JUST FOR
YOUR COMMENT ON TOTAL COMPLAINTS --
AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TOTAL
COMPLAINTS WERE ABOUT SIXTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE THOUSAND OF THOSE
WERE COMPLAINTS THAT ROLLED OVER
FROM THE PRIOR YEAR.
PERCY CL OVERALL ACROSS ALL
FACILITIES.
THANK YOU.
I THINK THE THE ONE MESSAGE WHEN
I HEAR IT FROM YOU AS WELL AS
FROM THE MEMBERS IS ANNUAL
EXPECT INSPECTIONS ARE A GOOD
THING.
AND I THINK THAT IN THE END WE
ALL BENEFIT SO HEARING THAT FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE YOU KNOW
THAT IN THE FUTURE WHEN THE
OTHER BUDGET REQUESTS.
YOU SAY YOU TOLD ME YOU WANTED
ANNUAL RICK ANNUAL INSPECTIONS.
SO WITH THAT.
YES DID YOU WANT TO SORRY THE
TABLE WAS KIND OF FLOODING WHEN
I GET GET UP THERE IS THE GAME
PERMIT FINANCE.
AS WENT OUT TO EXTENT THAT THERE
IS WE ADOPTED ME IF WE DROP IT
ME AND EXPECT IS ON GOING.
GIVEN THAT THE FUNDING THAT
WE'RE HAVING RIGHT NOW TO
PROVIDE THIS AND EXPRESSIONS
FEDERAL FUNDING ONLY.
THERE WILL BE A GENERAL FUND
PRESSURE IN THE IN THE FUTURE
JEFF ACOSTA OUT YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO DO -- ANYA EXPANSION ONCE
DEBORAH FUND IS DEPLETED.
HE TELLS ONE IN THE OUT YEARS
THAT WOULD BE EXPECTED -- HEALTH
CORRECT THE I DON'T NOT SURE HOW
LONG HAVE THE FEDERAL FUNDING
THE BILL FOR HOW LONG.
THE TWO WE GOT -- TO BUCKETS IF
YOU WILL OF THAT CCTV CHEAP
FUNDING FROM A AND THIS CURRENT
YEAR'S BUDGET AND THEN AGAIN IN
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET.
EACH ONE OF THOSE BUCKETS IS IS
CAN BE EXPENDED OVER A PERIOD OF
THREE YEARS BUT IF YOU WANTED TO
CONTINUE DOING ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS DURING THAT PERIOD
OF TIME IT WOULD PROBABLY BE TWO
YEARS FROM NOW.
THAT THE GENERAL FUND WOULD HAVE
TO BEGIN TO BACK FILL THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THAT CONCLUDES OUR AT
ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR AND BEFORE WE GO TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE WHY DON'T WE GO TO A
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE FIRST VOTE IS FOR ISSUE
EIGHT WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
LINES FIFTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE AND THIRTY SIX MISTER
PATTERSON.
MISTER PATTERSON I SECOND VOTE
IS FOR LINE FIFTEEN OF ISSUE
EIGHT MISTER PATTERSON. TO
PATTERSON OF VOTING.
THIRD VOTE IS FOR LINE NINETEEN
OF ISSUE.
EIGHT MR PATERSON NOT VOTING.
FOURTH PHùIS FOR LINE TWENTY
THREE OF ISSUE.
EIGHT MISTER PATTERSON.
MISTER PATTERSON OF VOTING.
FIFTH VOTE IS FOR THE LINE
THIRTY SIX OF ISSUE EIGHT MISTER
PATTERSON.
MISTER PATTERSON NO THANK YOU.
THAT CONCLUDES ALL THE VOTING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE ON LIMóN LET.
ELIMINATING FINGERPRINT
LICENSING FEE EXEMPTION.
I CAN HAVE URBAN DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES IN THIS IS AGAIN --
RELATED TO COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING -- SEN FOR THE LAST
SIXTEEN YEARS -- LEGISLATURE HAS
HAS ANNUALLY ADOPTED LANGUAGE
THAT.
AND IT'S THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN IS
ALWAYS CONFUSING IT ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE TO CHARGE --
PROVIDERS FOR THE FINGERPRINT
FEE -- THAT ARE TO THE
FINGERPRINT FEES THAT ARE
CHARGED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE FBI AND ALSO FOR
THE CHILD ABUSE -- CASE INDEX --
THOSE THREE FEES.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND THREE
HAD PARK HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN --
IN STATUTE CREATED AN EXEMPTION
SO THAT INDIVIDUAL WOULD NOT
HAVE TO PAY THOSE FEES.
AND THEN EACH YEAR AFTER THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN US THE
ABILITY TO ALLOW THOSE FEES TO
BE PASSED THROUGH.
THIS TRAILER BILL CONTINUES THAT
EXEMPTION FOR ANOTHER YEAR
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
WE WILL HOLD.
NEXT NEXT -- WITNESS. ONE SAYING
NO ALL RIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
NO COMMENTS ON THIS RIVETING.
SUBJECT.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT CONCLUDES ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
LET'S GOOD ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX PETER BAKER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT I'LL TAKE THE LEAD ON
SIX A AN IMMIGRATION -- IN THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CONTINUE
IMMIGRATION FUNDING AT OUT OF
MUCH HIGHER ON GOING LEVEL -- WE
WE ARE ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS HERE THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK
ACROSS THE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE THE SUBSETS WITHIN OUR
IMMIGRATION SERVICES FUNDING
PROGRAM WERE ASKING. FOR SIX
PERMANENT POSITIONS TO CONTINUE
TO OPERATE THOSE PROGRAMS -- WE
DO A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF SITE
VISITS TO OUR LEGAL SERVICES
PROVIDERS WE PROVIDE A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THEM.
IN HOW TO DO THIS BUSINESS WE DO
A LOT OF CONNECTING THEM WITH
EACH OTHER -- AND THAT KIND OF
THAT ALREADY REQUIRES -- WARM
BODIES TO IT TO DO ALL OF THAT
WORK.
ADDITIONALLY THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRACTING WORKLOAD
FOR US AT THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL
ON BOTH ON THE PROGRAM SIDE.
AS WELL AS THE ADMINISTRATION
SIDE SO WE'RE ASKING -- FOR SOME
POSITIONS TO FULLY SUPPORT THIS
PROGRAM AS WELL.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
AN ON ITEM BEING -- THIS IS FOR
STAINING IT SERVICES ESSENTIALLY
THIS IS -- WE HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO BE MORE EFFICIENT IN OUR
CONTRACTING AND FINDING NEW WAYS
TO DO THINGS.
AS WELL AS SOME PROJECTS
CONCLUDE AND THEN ROLL OFF
BEFORE EVERYTHING IS COMPLETELY
EXPENDED -- IT IT LITERALLY HAS
BEEN COBBLED TOGETHER FROM AND
FROM A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
SOURCES IN PLACES BUT WE NEED
THE STAFF TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
WE HAVE OVER.
SEVENTY LEGACY SYSTEMS -- OUT
THE DEPARTMENT THAT SUPPORT
CRITICAL WORK THAT WE'RE DOING --
AND AS WE TRY TO MODERNIZE AND
UPDATE THEM WE STILL NEED PEOPLE
TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON AND
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WORK AND FUNCTION.
AND SO THIS PROVIDES THE FUNDING
FOR THAT BUT IT JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THE PLACES
THAT WE FOUND FUNDING TO THIS NO.
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS WE'VE
SWITCHED OVER TELECOM FROM ONE
PROVIDER TO ANOTHER TO A VOICE
OVER INTERNET PROTOCOL PROVIDER
WHICH IS SAVED US A COUPLE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR --
AS AS WE DO IT SO THAT WAS ONE
OF THE PLACES WE WERE ABLE.
TO BUY WERE WERE ALSO TRYING TO
ELIMINATE OUR USE OF SOME
RETIRED A NEW IT TENDS ON
VARIOUS PROJECTS TO ACTUALLY
HIRE STAFF BECAUSE HAVING STAFF
IS MORE RELIABLE THAN RETIRED
ANNUITANTS.
I DON'T THINK THEY'D LIKE TO
HEAR YOU SAY THAT.
VERY GOOD THEY LIKE THEY LIKE
THE TIME OFF WANTS TO RETIRE SO.
YES THAT THE THE AS THEY WOULD.
OF VERY GOOD THE NEXT WITNESS.
I'M HAPPY TO HIT SEE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE.
I'M SORRY YES.
MIKE.
THE ELECTRONIC BENEFIT TRANSFER
THE FRUIT AND VEGETABLE PILOT --
THIS WAS -- IN RESPONSE TO
LEGISLATION THAT WAS ENACTED
LAST YEAR -- THERE'S OF THE IS
WE HELD A KICK OFF.
MEETING IN FEBRUARY.
WE HAVE AN INTERNAL MEETING THE
MIDDLE OF THIS MONTH -- WITH --
OFFICE OF SYSTEMS INTEGRATION
REBT VENDOR -- AND OURSELVES TO
SCOPE OUT WHAT IT WILL TAKE TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THIS ON A
TECHNICAL BASIS.
THAT WILL INFORM THE WRITING OF
A REQUEST OF FOR APPLICATIONS --
IN THE PROGRAM WE EXPECTED
SEPTEMBER THIS YEAR TO RELEASE
THAT TO TO THE COMMUNITY -- TO
TO GET IN GET INTERESTS FROM
FOLKS -- BETWEEN THEIR TIME TO
RESPOND OUR TIME TO EVALUATE
RESPONSES AND ACTUALLY BEING
ABLE TO TO KICK OFF FOR THINKING --
SOMETIME IN IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY TO ACTUALLY HAVE THE
PROJECTS -- KICKED OFF -- IN
THAT KICK OFF WILL INCLUDE SOME
DESIGN AND DEVELOPMENT AND
COMMUNITY OUTREACH TO LET PEOPLE
KNOW THAT IT'S AVAILABLE --
GOING LIVE JULY -- TWENTY TWENTY
AND THEN IT SHOULD BE OPERATING
WITH A REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
BY THE JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO RATHER THAN
TRYING TO WRITE THAT DOWN I'M
HAPPY TO LEAVE THAT INFORMATION
BEHIND WITH THE STAFF OF THE
COMMITTEE I ONLY HAVE ONE COPY
WITH ME -- SHOULD HAVE A LOOK AT
THAT LEVEL.
SO MAKE A COPY.
APOLOGIES THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
CELLO WITH THE LA L. -- WE'VE
REVIEWED ALL THREE OF THESE
PROPOSALS AND HAVE NO COMMENT
SPECIFIC.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
LET'S OPEN THIS UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NO COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS.
I I I WOULD WOULD ASK AND I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE US THE THE
PRINT OUT.
OF THE TO KEEP STAFF APPRISED OF
THE THE STATUS OF SO THAT SHE
CAN.
NOTIFY US OUR FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
DIVISION -- DOES A A REGULAR
UPDATE FOR ALL OF LEGISLATIVE
STAFF AND ONE IS INCLUDED IN
THAT.
THIS IS A BET THIS IS EXCITING
ACTUALLY I'M PLEASED WITH ALL OF
THEM BUT I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THE FRUITS AND VEGETABLES.
VERY GOOD -- THANK YOU THAT
CONCLUDES ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX ALL RIGHT WE WILL BE HOLDING
THOSE ITEMS OPEN WILL BE ACTING
ON THEM SOON.
WE'VE ALREADY ADDRESSED ISSUE
NUMBER.
SEVEN AND WITH THAT WE ARE DONE.
THANK YOU THIS CONCLUDES
[inaudible]
OF BUDGET SUBWAY AND HEARING FOR
TODAY